bang bang what's up guys that's right
salute salute while Wall Street is
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get our lunch money right
welcome to lunch money on Monday what is
it April 14th that's April 13th I'm just
kidding with you the beautiful and
genius miss Mara Nova is here with me I
hope you guys had a great weekend
let's get into the topics ok so you're
talking loud now that people can hear
you talking visa is working with some
crypto startup like on a co-branded visa
debit card that will give you bitcoin
rewards do you know anything about this
yeah they're tricking everybody who's
missing this is how they trick the media
who they're like the tenth person to do
this by the way I'm a huge fan fold big
fan big fold at fol D app huge fan love
the idea it's taking a debit card it's
taking a debit card that works on the
visa network they go anywhere you swipe
it you can get rewards back in Bitcoin
etc there's a number of other players
including crypto calm and others who
have these debit cards huge
I think inflection point for adoption
because obviously now people can
basically spam by just swiping the card
but I love how every time somebody does
this they go out to the press the press
writes a big story hold on
this is different because folders she
does it with the finger the matumbo
style Bowl this part of visas in tech
fast track program or the other
companies part of that I feel like this
is really smart for visa to keep its
finger on the pulse in case they might
want to get into Bitcoin and they might
many people don't cry many people don't
know visa has an entire crypto division
run by a guy named guy and he's also not
really spoke almost the same and they're
super super smart they're super into
stable coins they're into Bitcoin
they're into all kinds of payments you
know etc and so literally they have a
head of crypto
who's a guy I've talked to before super
smart and they definitely understand the
one potential disruption to their
business and then also to they've got
some ideas as to how they can benefit or
kind of capture part of the upside of
crypto as well do we think MasterCard is
doing the same thing I don't know about
MasterCard I wish felt like we have you
had a MasterCard you were kind of like a
little bit like second-class like like
Visa was the big one and the MasterCard
and then like American Express came out
of nowhere trying to leap forward but
like I don't know this is just like
everyday man or woman's car it's like
Bud Light but like water for the common
man Visa card for the common man no
problem let's move on to the next one
Amazon it was all hiring 75,000 more
workers as demand rises due to
coronavirus and that's in addition to
the hundred thousand positions in the
last month
so these claim to have a hundred seventy
five thousand open jobs well new
positions okay and is this because they
have that many employees leaving or
because there's increasing demand
increasing demand and they're hiring
additional warehouse and delivery
workers across the country is there I'm
assuming an explosion of orders right
from everyone sitting at home being like
what should I do let me get drunk and
just online shop yeah or you know you
try to buy toilet paper which Amazon
seems to not have do you guys want to
know a funny story the man who works at
the door in our apartment building in
New York City every single time we walk
in he just starts laughing when he sees
Polina and he says young lady any
fingers are over like this I come here
and when she comes over he goes in the
back and gets an Amazon package and I
will ask Glenn every single time what is
in this box and she was like I don't
even remember she does or she's just
like a you shouldn't do any shopping but
on Amazon she's a Shopaholic
that's not sure it's like Etsy I'm not a
big I'm not the biggest Amazon fan
something wait why not are you not a
Bezos believer you see I just did that I
should trademark that Bezos believe yeah
I struggle I struggle what Oh
because it's dick pics
No all right I think it's you know a lot
of the small businesses that are on
Amazon and some of the fees they take
how they treat them just a lot of the
things I'm not sure how I feel about it
but is it a pure capitalism I don't care
I'm just all right you just use have
strong feelings yeah and then and then
those pictures came out and then like
the new no I'm saying no sure sure yeah
take a look I know some of you guys saw
him leave comments it was like we think
that his phone was hacked by the Saudis
isn't that what it said well I think
that's what he claims but then like
there's also a claim that hurt his new
girlfriend's brother just leaked the
information to me that seems more
plausible than the Saudis hacked you but
maybe I think he just said hey that's
the richest man in the world like let's
get paid let's get paid exactly all
right Amazon by the way
Amazon hiring spree this is a huge deal
because there was also in New York there
are people who walked out there was a
bunch of protests etc around the working
conditions and because of coronavirus
they're trying to do a bunch of things
like get the mascot than PPE PPE
personal protective equipment and also
doing things like trying to test them as
they go in like check their temperature
as they go in and out and stuff so like
it's just all just this company like
this is you know absolute salt of the
earth grind it out logistics you got to
get a box with a good from point A to
point B and do it during an economic
shutdown in but it's not their fault
that they don't have the toilet expect
all people like you the people like you
who bought all the toilet paper one day
I came home and it was never seen paper
in my life um was a good toilet paper
yes no this is what I was gonna say if
you guys might be acid the toilet paper
good she shook she's so sure so we just
move on no I
people my friends that um if you want a
really good Jeff Bezos slash Amazon
documentary there's a free one on PBS
it's really good should they just search
PBS alright go watch it that's free
content for you Bob's back Bobby boy
what up Bobby boy from Disney is back
don't tell me to go ahead I go ahead
when I want to go ahead I'm will be in
so much trouble later today just
everyone pray for me good so Bob Iger
toys in February shocked the world by
saying that he was gonna leave his
retired from his job as CEO of Disney he
was a very well-liked CEO he was
succeeded by Bob see that's what they
call him I don't actually ever top
traffic chapman yeah
Travis Nick nobody cares about the
second Bob okay so sorry about the
second Bob goes by Bob see kind of like
The Bachelor you know it's like Bob a
Bob see Bob P yeah but they're but just
be clear Bob Iger who's the boss Bob he
only goes yeah he's just back here and
goodbye bye-bye
he goes by Bob's other guys gotta go bye
Bob see just literally just stuff the
necks and a lot like a little child so
Bob steps down well take a step well
well became the executive chair yeah one
from CEO to executive chairman executive
chairman kind of just like a chairman
vers executive chairman Oh like the
difference a chairman and an executive
chairman executive chairman my everyone
has a different understanding or belief
in it but executive chairman essentially
is like Cassville got some operational
control around here right like not
really not really until you do what he's
doing right now which is I'm the
executive chairman and you work for me
and I'm gonna tell you what to do versus
chairman is like more I am the person
who leads the board but I don't have
necessary operational control liking Bob
Iger well so Bob Iger yes has reasserted
control and kind of like said Bob see
hold up I need to like fix this so it
according to the New York Times at least
he's stepping back why are you looking
at me like that
I'm just winging it there's a revolution
going on at Disney there's literally a
coop he's coming back he's taking
control not at all he never left this is
the whole charade that goes on going
into the beginning of 2020 there was an
incredible explosion in q3 q4 2019 of
CEO stepping down the writing was on the
wall it wasn't a surprise to anybody
companies were over leveraged we were at
late stages of a bull market it was
obvious that this thing was going to
turn over at some point whether it was
one month three months six months 12
months whatever who's gonna have to end
and so what a bunch of CEOs did they got
near the edge of the plane they said hey
guys it's been a [ __ ] blast and they
just pulled the ripcord and they
parachuted on out of the situation and
now the planes are crashing literally
and everyone's like damn I should have
jumped out with the parachute with like
the CEO did instead I'm stuck in this
plane that's on fire crashing both
engines are out and the grounds
approaching really fast so Bob Iger who
thinks that you know he could solve
every problem he basically cut his
parachute and he dove back into the
plane he goes I'm gonna fix this thing
okay so some people are saying that like
Bob I kind of saw the coronavirus thing
coming in December and it was like you
know what this would be good a good note
for me to end on before it gets really
bad I'm not sure if that's true but do
you think that it's better for him to
have stepped down and come back versus
just continued his tenure well one I
think it's complete garbage for any
executive to do what he's doing right
now which is to make an abrupt decision
to step down right he he'd said before
that he was going to step down the next
like 18 miles but the plan publicly
stated was that it was gonna be like 18
months he then saw the coronavirus
coming he basically got scared and tried
to run away he got because he sat down
immediately
effective immediately early enough that
said effectively immediate today he's
stepping down which was not the original
plan so coronavirus accelerated that and
then when he said he's stepping away and
saying okay you're in charge now all of
a sudden he's coming back around whether
explicitly saying it or not and
reestablishing himself and so imagine if
you're an employer direct reports the
new CEO you well do I talked about
or Baba or I talked to both Bob's can I
just ask who's bad leadership who's just
who's to say that Bob see wouldn't have
done a good job I thought I'm gonna see
what Bob sees gonna do Bob you want to
see Bob see knock it out of park yeah by
the way look I'm a big fan of Bob Iger I
actually think Bob iger's incredibly
intelligent and from everything that
I've heard and read he's killed it for
Disney did a fantastic job watching his
master class come on sometimes you get a
little tired need a little catnap even
though the afternoon you know it happens
to the best of us Christian eat some ice
cream little chocolate chip cookies no
problem but here's the problem is that
this is like a this is literally like
Michael Jordan hanging on to his career
still thinking he's the goat and goes to
the Washington Wizards you don't even
know what that means but basically what
happened is Michael Jordan at the end of
his career wanted to play so bad and
everyone was like dude it's over and he
had retired and I kind of came back as
head like an owner I think if I remember
correctly he started playing he's like
42 years old playing in watt for the
Washington Wizards everyone's like dude
that's a greatest basketball player of
all time but like I'm gonna dunk on him
right now because he's just 42 he can't
jump as hot either too mean like you're
hanging on to a dream but your body
can't do it anymore some professional
athlete do this all the time but I think
the leadership is a little different
than like your body breaking down is it
you can be a great leader in 42 or 87
I'm not gonna argue that you can't do
that but there's something to be said
about having the confidence and the
people that replace you to let them do
the job like even if Bob Iger steps away
at some point in the future right that
actually steps away Bob sees gonna be
walking around like a kid who got beat
up at the lunch table at the cafeteria
you're saying like old man who's gonna
come beat me up this time I'm personally
just want Walt Disney to come back that
guy's thanks okay ready I'm moving on
yeah we got seven minutes can we get it
done yes so we got no new emoji will be
unveiled in the year 2021 we gotta wait
until 2020 to like the Coolibar scheme
for everything thank you bro go ahead
what emoji do you want to add there's
two
many a mode you ever gone to the emoji
like the keyboard you just scroll down
you're like why is there this plunger
why do you need a plunger yeah you don't
have a place for example yeah I think
there is one I don't think there's a
plot of this you don't even know what a
platypus yes it's like with that flat
thing is what I deal with on a daily
basis they're my friends all right so
what emoji do you want added what emoji
do you want at it so I can send it to
you what a mode you do that you want
added can we get a Carol basket it was
it was Carol [ __ ] Baskin is that what
you want you want a Carol basket emoji
you know I don't want to Carol by the
way can we talk about first second
silent emoji but on tick-tock there's a
sound which is Carol killed her husband
and you won't change my mind and people
are creating these massive dances
they're going viral on tick-tock simply
to this long time by Carol Baskin
killing her her husband which is pretty
funny well so I pull up tick-tock and
you got so into it and then we watched
like a long feed of people dancing
tonight I like shiny things you know I'm
saying I like naps on the afternoon
little ice-cream Oreos all of a sudden
tick-tock I'm like a little rat I just
start scrolling along looking at all the
videos I take Swain who Charlie oh and
then the drama so okay I've got a gossip
columnist here with me on the in the
tick tock community all right so no new
emojis is there one that you want should
we show a petition no doesn't matter I
don't know honestly like I don't really
care about you know I like the chicken
one the chicken would like that it's
like hatching I like the fire emoji
because you can just drop flames flames
let's see leave a comment and tell us
what your most used emoji is in the in
the comments but I'll tell you right now
that mine is it's probably the heart no
it's the hell this is my the laughing
emoji face and then praying hands and
then the fire - the laughing emoji the
case in the alarm no good the other way
wait which down the other way
laughing you have two laughing emojis it
goes down but I use the chicken Oh Anna
sees the school one and why do you have
to climb
oh that's what you said to me okay yeah
dead right that that's the new thing
just dead and I'm like am I supposed to
be dead or are you just dead cuz you're
laughing so hard cuz I'm so emoji that I
really wanted it's okay I'll think of it
sorry you can tell us in a week when you
[Laughter]
say your piece
no I'm good Bobby's back lunch money
winner goes to Erik Cassidy Mary's cast
watching daily since lunch money's
origin what does that mean what is a
missin main stream media you didn't know
that I was trying to figure the MMS
anyway you rather like that that's like
that's code on the internet for msn is
you know like the liars they're all
twisting the facts
I appreciate the general that's me
reminding me to be kind to my friends
Eric shout out man
we got him a hundred bucks he's gonna go
buy some Bitcoin with it he said
hopefully he's okay with me saying that
and America's crushing but I appreciate
everyone that I was shocked at how many
people went took the URL on Friday we
did it there were great jokes plain and
I actually gotten an argument as to who
won I won but oh wait but it sounded
good my favorite sure it's a time
between my my bedazzled sleeves and when
you asked me if Joe should be exonerated
and you said he should be exotic
does that make you laugh if you guys
ever want to know how easy it is to
entertain Polina you get a crash course
my favorite joke was barrel [ __ ]
Baskin
that would happen can you imagine if
Halloween doesn't happen this year how
many people are gonna be disappointed
they can't pull out their best Tiger
king outfits you're still gonna they're
gonna wear them yeah zoom are they
should we wear Halloween costumes on
this no why no you have a costume on
every day I'm just me all right guys
listen we appreciate you guys tuning in
we're having a blast
recording lunch money while let's run
ate or while Wall Street is trying to
get rich the rest of us just trying to
get a lunch money right every day noon
ish why ish because we don't have our
[ __ ] together although I will say since
Polina has been coming on we've gotten
our [ __ ] together much better and so
it's sometime around noon maybe 5:00
p.m. whatever you'll see this coming out
maybe so yeah leave us a comment share
the video tell us whatever you want us
to cover and we will keep recording
these until we either stop having fun or
Polina gets mad at me so we'll see you
guys tomorrow
shox that hasn't happened yet bye guys
be kind to your friends